foreign
was telling me that my mom would be
really worried and show her like the new
spots coming off my back and she would
always say to her like you can't show me
anything because it makes her feel
different I know that you grew up in a
tough neighborhood but you're now in a
tough industry so what is a lesson you
learned from the way you grew up that
you applied to every day doing this job
not taking those is an answer my biggest
challenge is earlier on was that no one
knew where to place me because I never
worked with someone who looked like me
before and this is an industry of
obviously how you look right there's
never been someone to walk this road
before so do I actually go for it can I
be successful in it successful is an
understatement after being taken under
the wing a fashion photographer Nick
Knight Winnie Harlow was ready to walk
the walk
I worked at lucenzo which was funny
because I would look at the models in
the zenza and be like oh I wish I could
do that and I ended up watching for
Victoria's Secret which was insane
[Music]
[Applause]
oh I got to see myself in Victoria's
Secret
it's insane all right
today Winnie Harlow is one of Fashion's
top models turning her differences into
her best asset it's funny to me now that
I've actually created a lane for myself
in this industry that there was never a
lane set forth for me people would be
like she's only a model because her skin
and I'm like well it was actually the
opposite I was never supposed to be a
model because of my skin it's
double-edged sword but there's Beauty in
it
[Music]